let's bring in a Joe Theismann who joins
us good morning Joe thanks for joining
us how are you welcome and good to catch
up with ya turn on that list is journey
they are yeah that's what I thought yeah
yeah journeys part of that soft rock in
the 70s yeah mm-hmm yeah what am i
landed i favorite band let me ask a
couple of things here that have to do
with you know Washington DC that you
know so well at what point do you think
we see Dewayne Haskins here what has to
happen first I well first of all I think
that it depends a little bit on Col
McCoy I believe he's going to work this
week he's been acting he's not been put
on IR so if Case Keenum something
happens to him and he can't go I think
the next alternative would be cold and
then it would be Duane I just can't see
where it makes a lot of sense to rush
Blaine Blaine out on the football field
because people want to see him play
coaches evaluate and you know maybe the
evaluation this is not quite ready yet I
mean there's a you know and everybody
says well look with Daniel Jones did in
New York and look at you know what is
happening with him two different
scenarios Daniels played 30 football
games in college Dwayne's only played 13
football games at Ohio State the speed
of this game is entirely different than
it is at the college level and we're
struggling you know running the football
which we need from a support standpoint
I think when the Giants win with Daniel
I figure well sink one will be there and
you know we can lean on him a little bit
to transition the young man in we
haven't had the ability to be able to do
that even though Adrian continues to to
pound and pound the pound we just
haven't got the yards out of it so I I
would venture to say it would be the
latter part of the year if at all maybe
the last quarter of the year if at all
what about Jay Gruden's future no I
think he even said at the start of the
year if we don't make the playoffs then
I'm not going to be the head coach here
do you think I think it's yeah I mean
but it isn't tongue-in-cheek I think he
realized
is that you know he has to produce in
this year but once again we're here we
are leading the National Football League
on players on I our three games 11 guys
on I are the last two years it's been a
before this years been like 40 46 guys
on IR and you know there are there are
ones in the National Football League and
there are tubes and if you're playing
with tons against ones you're not going
to win a lot of football games I think
there's a lot of pressure on Jay I mean
we I thought there was a lot of pressure
last week against Chicago but going to
play the New York Giants in New York
where you wouldn't say that they're a
juggernaut or even competing it for the
title in this division but if they don't
show up and play a good football game
and win this football game
he will go up even higher than it is
right now and it's up pretty high now
let me ask a couple other situations to
comment on the Cleveland Browns all this
hype Rex Ryan came out and says Baker
Mayfield's overrated as hell and then
went on to explain what he was doing
wrong here what do you make of the
Cleveland Browns situation here and in
particular Baker Mayfield why I think
first of all you owe Dale Beckham is
gonna create attention no matter where
he is whether he brings it upon himself
which he loves to do or because you see
kids come you look at they run
highlights of kids making one-handed
catches and Odell was the first to do it
so good first do everybody sort of
points to you I think Joe I think they
have a football team with Jarvis Landry
you know they have a football team is
very talented their defense doesn't get
talked about enough and Baker is still a
young kid he runs around a lot he makes
plays he makes some throws that were our
errant and we forget that he's very
young in this game how good is he at
times he's very good other times he's
still learning through and working
through the process
Freddie kitchens went from coordinator
to head coach so there's a transition
there I think Baker is entertaining
I think he's cocky as all get-out which
you know me damn yeah I live by a theory
it's you don't believe in yourself who's
going to believe in yet
I you know he's a great place to start
with this franchise and I think he's
he's gonna be okay it's just gonna take
time he's gonna have good games gonna
have bad games what do you see with
Aaron Rodgers with this new offense with
new head coach how do we see the old
Aaron Rodgers the old Aaron Rodgers to
me was I call a little bit of street
ball Aaron would drop back he would wait
for things to either break down or
develop and he would use his great
athleticism to get out of the pocket and
make throws that only he could make see
this is the thing that's unique about
Aaron he's the greatest pure passer in
my opinion this game has ever seen
nobody spins it like him nobody has
accuracy like him nobody has the release
that you guys now there's been different
individuals that have one of those
things maybe two but never three that he
can do I think what Matt has done with
this offenses try and give them a little
bit more support try to temper him a
little bit say make the throws when you
have to because I know you can do it but
don't try and carry the burden of this
football team just on your shoulders
whether we win or lose but the other
guys participate and be a facilitator
that's what we are at the quarterback
position get the ball out of your hands
into the hands of the guys to make plays
let the defense go do their job which by
the way their defense is playing better
than it has in years and you and if a
kicker has to make a kick then that's
and then so be it but so much has been
all about the focus of just Aaron
Rodgers you know if this is it is his
football team but sometimes at the
quarterback position and I saw this I
saw Brett Favre do the same thing you
take so much responsibility on success
or failure that it starts to hurt your
game and I think Aaron now is playing if
you might want to call it a little bit
more conservatively and and actually a
bit more effectively and he also went
against a couple of good defenses in
Chicago in Minnesota and Denver was
supposed to be a good defense so I you
know against the banged up Philadelphia
team at home tonight you know maybe we
see a little bit more of the old Aaron
Rodgers I was also curious about this
when you look at the you know when we
call Tom Brady the greatest quarterback
of all time
you know it's not going to be yardage
it's all gonna be touchdowns it's gonna
be Super Bowls but
let's say could Patrick mahomes be the
greatest quarterback of all time when
it's all said and done based on just
stats and not necessarily the number of
Super Bowl wins could you see a scenario
like that I think Patrick mahomes is a
special football player I think that's
the way we have to look at him now I
don't think you can bring his name into
a conversation about being the greatest
so early into his career and and let me
qualify why I believe Tom Brady is the
greatest Super Bowl certainly are a
factor but I mean you know he's won most
of them bye-bye kicks uh Adam Vinatieri
different people have made kicks for him
different plays that he has made tom is
the greatest because what he has around
him changes every year Dan if you do if
you have the same people in the studio
you had the same guys around and I watch
the show you know you had a rhythm you
know how to play off one another in Toms
case it's hard to get a rhythm yes he
has Julian now it doesn't have drunk now
all of a sudden they went from the tight
end slide based offense to a wide
receiver based offense with the addition
of Josh and Dorsett plan and so the
tight end position like two weeks ago
had one catch
which if Gronk was there you know that
wouldn't happen so there's been so much
change around Tom and yet he still plays
at the highest of levels and they win
football game and not just win them this
year they're blowing people out and
that's another team is you get that kind
of play out of their offense with the
defense the way it's playing you have to
try and out score them and you can't
because the other side won't let you but
that that's why when I look at Thomond
and of course joe Montana's name comes
into the conversation always about the
greatest in the game but Joe had a very
constant group of people around him
tom has not tom's had tremendous change
around him and yet the results are still
exactly the same that's what I think
makes him the greatest of all time if
you had one game to win aside from
yourself who would be your quarterback
hahahaha you're kind I appreciate it I
would substitute somebody for me I would
say
because he's proven it time and time
again that you know he knows how to
manage a clock he knows how to handle
timeouts
I want the coaches burn timeouts in the
first and second quarter of football
games and I just shake my head the game
has evolved and it's changed I grant
that but there are fundamentals in the
game that don't change and that is you
have to preserve your timeouts at all
cost you need them at the end of a half
you need them at the end of a game you
can't and you can't be taken 5-yard
delay a game penalties because you can't
keep the signals and my god you're
talking to the quarterback what kind of
conversation do you have to have in 40
seconds since you can't get the ball
snapped in that very spot I mean the
fundamentals are still a part of the
game but could you imagine coach gills
in your in your headset talking to you
no it was hard enough with him on the
second but it is the one thing that I
noticed with these younger quarterbacks
and I watched Haskins in pre-season and
I said you got to get to the line
quicker you got to process it and you
know that that time is you know it's of
the essence when you're in the NFL and I
see these younger quarterbacks and they
take a little too much time Baker's been
doing that and I thought Haskins did
that in the preseason did you notice
that I do and what happens sometimes is
each offense buries in its verbage they
use numbers names colors all kinds of
different de notions when you think
about how you want to call a play that
there could be 22 characters in just one
play and you can't start to say and all
of a sudden that was said wrong and
start over you can't do that and so from
a quarterback you have to get it out of
your mouth then you have to get to the
line of scrimmage and what's really
important and I don't think people
realize is you need all of a sudden a
snapshot this picture in your mind of
where all the receivers are going to be
and then we're the ball is snapped you
study the defense and then you find the
hole all that is done in about 2.3
seconds so from the time you call the
play you have to see it you have to
visualize it then you have to get to the
line of scrimmage and make any changes
that are necessary then you have to snap
get back and get rid of the football or
if you're in the gun you have to pick
out which side you want to look at and
which guy you want to focus on it goes a
lot deeper than just getting it out of
your mouth and saying this is what we're
going to run but and this is what I say
young guys struggle daniel Jones for
Kendall he wins a football game because
it can't miss a kick by the way the Matt
gay the kicker for the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers please get rid of those shoes
please you're a rookie
you don't need lemon lime juice okay win
games and everybody will talk about you
and I do the first thing I thought is oh
my goodness what are those things but
never they had a ball picked off in the
middle of the fourth quarter and late
third the guy hit safety right in the
hand I process it they go on to win the
football game and I ask this question of
some of my friends and everybody says
wow look at the job he did I said if he
loses that football game let's take the
Giants lose are we talking about Daniel
the same way that we're talking about
him now having won his first football
game probably not but you saw glimpses
of athleticism that you haven't seen at
that position with that team in a long
time so I think that's all the Giants
are doing is they're they're showing
their fan base there is hope this is our
future and you know that's why I went
back to the Dwayne Haskins like at what
point does management Daniel Snyder's
say I got to get people back in the
stands here and I'm gonna go to Dwayne
Haskins to let them see the future so I
I think the wind and if you win you're
going to get people in the stands you
know they lost about seven of the last
eight I think at the end of the season
we've lost we belong it's a fan base
that is is tired they're looking for
something to get excited about and
you're right
what did Wayne would excite them but if
he's not ready to go that excitement
would be very short-lived and you would
subject him to a possible beating both
mentally and physically that could
affect him going forward if he is the
future yeah there's a process there's a
process that people just aren't willing
to look at look at what Patrick is done
and you look what Sam's doing in New
York I mean you see these young guys
come in and start to play but then I
always think it's Joey Harrington who
just got the living daylights beat out
of them or David Mr David Carr was
another one Andrew Luck is basically
left
because he's just tired of all the the
beatings that he's taken because of the
punishment that he's taken so I think
it's a it's a it's a very tenuous
situation when you make that decision
and under what circumstance do you want
to put that young player in I'll leave
you with this what was the play call
where riggan scored the touchdown to win
the Superbowl 70 chip now is there is
there anything
give me the play when you call it in the
huddle you just say that no it's it's
goal line formation 70 chip let's get
this and roll long that was the
conversation does Riggins say anything
no John never said anything unless like
unless I called the wrong play and I
sent him some place with no blocking
many would turn around just look at me I
mean did I get this I get this look like
what are you kidding there's guys over
here the line I was supposed to go left
I went I did that to him once I said I'm
so done with no blocking this game five
yards and he looks at me said hey Johnny
mate you got five Hey great to talk to
you Joe we appreciate your time as
always
you too need to do well look forward to
catching up right that's Joe Theismann
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]